the day after Burfict was sent to the
showers prematurely in the game at
Indianapolis the NFL suspends him for
the rest of the season 12 games an
unprecedented suspension for an on-field
infraction Chris the prior record 5 set
by then Titans defensive tackle Albert
Haynesworth for removing the helmet of
then Cowboys Center Andre gurad and
stopping him on the forehead with a
cleat that was a five game suspension
and it was upheld on appeal this one
Chris I don't think they care if it's
upheld on appeal I don't think it will
be upheld on appeal it is too it is too
much in light of what his past history
the whole idea of progressive discipline
you you punish someone and if that
doesn't work you punish them a little
bit more and if that doesn't work you
accelerated by small amounts you don't
go from a three game suspension to a
twelve game suspension actually last
year they didn't suspend him for a
couple of illegal hits against the
Steelers right because they were
concerned it was going to get overturned
and they didn't want a message to be
sent to all of the locker rooms that
they were overreaching this year they
don't care if they're overreaching they
want perfect off the field and I think
it's going to be cut to six games eight
games maybe even four games and I don't
think the league cares they wanted that
full news cycle of the message being
sent that they are not going to tolerate
this guy yeah no they can't tolerate it
not this day and age football is under
assault right now I mean people are
looking at it as barbaric enough I mean
I've talked to you a million times about
you know my kids playing this first year
or tackled football and I got parents
all the time asking me about like hey
are you worried or you do you know so
this is an issue and the NFL is trying
to clean up the game and Vantaa is
perfect there's just there's no room for
it anymore in this current day in the
NFL the rules should never have been a
room for it with that type of play when
you see I'm all for physical football
taking it up to the edge I get that but
that's like reckless launching at a
guy's head in a situation where hey I
know we're trying to be physical he's on
a knee you still could have lowered your
shoulder and put your like shoulder into
his chest or something like that but he
intentionally lowered the
proud of his helmet and tried to explode
through Jack Doyle's head I mean that's
what he tried to do and I think the NFL
is completely correct uh suspend him for
the whole season two things real quick
yeah he was down but he wasn't down
because in the NFL you can get up and
keep going
and before last season that's a
perfectly legal maneuver that wasn't the
spearing type maneuver with the crown of
the helmet right into the guy it was
dipped it was lowered and it was the
violation of the rule that the NFL added
in 2018 and is enforcing more
aggressively in 2019 any lowering of the
helmet any contact to the helmet front
side top wherever if you do it you're
going to get penalized you're gonna get
fined and you may be ejected and or
suspended and you're history is a factor
and Perfect's history and reputation is
why it was a 12 game suspension right
and my guess is they just said enough
and Kris I won't be surprised if after
this season he gets the Colin Kaepernick
treatment and and the way I look at it
if you're going to blackballed Colin
Kaepernick for nothing and you've got a
guy who is you know a walking hazard to
his fellow player I'm not in favor of
any type of collusion or violation of
the rules that way but if the 32 teams
all simultaneously individually decide
we don't want to put this guy on the
field anymore then so be it and you
could argue he already should be out of
the NFL but maybe after what we saw
yesterday he will end up being a pariah
and deservedly so well yeah I mean I'm
I'm like I think there's a very real
chance that does happen
I mean it's risky it's almost like bad
off the field behavior there it's you
know I almost classify this as like I'm
not gonna feel sorry for you Oakland
Raiders you took a chance on a guy that
we knew always did this type of stuff
and we knew that if he had one more
infraction that it would be this type of
thing where it could be a long long
suspension
we all knew these were possibilities and
we all knew that there was a great
possibility of happening because it's
bonta's perfect there's no show no
governor really as far as when it comes
to this so let me ask you this now let
me ask this yeah why did you guys on
Bruton sign him because
vantes Burfict is a good football player
and he does bring an attitude to your
football team you know he does do that
he's physical over the over the middle
yes all of that stuff but at the same
time with him bringing that there's the
risk there and I'm certainly not gonna
feel bad just like with Antonio Brown we
had enough of information to say this
could happen so don't cry me a river'
when it does happen
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports